dr. shrink snapped mansis snapped my
friends oh hey I'm here to take on
Thanos I'm Laureen Tony Stark is very
late for brunch I'm like stuff this is
Earth's Mightiest show where we are
talking about all of the biggest stuff
in the Marvel Universe yeah like for
instance big news about what is coming
to the new streaming service Disney Plus
as they have announced two original
series the first is Marvel six one six a
documentary series exploring Marvel's
rich legacy of stories characters
creators and more the other is Marvel's
hero project which reveals the positive
change several young heroes are making
in their own communities keep an eye out
for these new Marvel shows coming soon
to Disney Plus which launches on
November 12th this July the Marvel
Ultimate Alliance series returns with
Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the black
order for the Nintendo switch you can
assemble a team of Marvel superheroes
including the Avengers guardians of the
galaxy and many others as you race to
stop Dennis and the Black Order from
unleashing cosmic chaos and you can pick
up Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the black
order when it hits stores and the
Nintendo eShop
on July 19 we are less than a week away
from Marvel Studios Avengers endgame so
make sure to get your tickets on sale
now and check out all of the action live
from the red carpet world premiere of
Marvel Studios Avengers endgame where
I'll be hosting the live stream you can
catch that on April 22nd on marvel.com
slash endgame premiere I cannot wait for
this week it is gonna be incredible oh
it will be an amazing week and in Lorien
we have both done premieres before I did
the Marvel Studios Avengers infinity war
premiere and that my head almost rolled
up my shoulders all the cool things are
there yeah and you got to be in that
cool tent full of all of the stuff for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
anniversary holy cow there's listen
there's already over a decade's worth of
Marvel Cinematic Universe trivia and
props and costumes so that was
incredible on its own and like the scope
of these premieres is massive what's
your favorite part my favorite part of
the premiere talking to movie stars
Hudson and hang out it's just so fun
because you know this is the moment
everybody gets to really celebrate the
film everybody's put in so much hard
work and this is just the party we
to be a part of it and it's live so
anything can happen you know sometimes
stars are crashing in on stars doing
interviews it's just really a good time
it is a good time you talk about a
celebration like it's also fun to see
stars and celebrities that are not in
the movie getting to hang out and be
fans and like n to take a step back and
be famous fans yeah cuz bigwigs is it
work yeah cuz we're all big nerds
together it's like the fun part is
everybody's just in the party I could
not be more excited to be at the
premiere this week yes well I'm gonna be
back here in New York City protecting
the Earth's Mightiest show bridge from
Marauders it's a terrible infestation
it's a problem but you better believe
I'm gonna be following along and you
should too on marvel.com slash endgame
premiere and all Marvel's social media
it's gonna be great you're all set right
there right guys still have to do a
little bit of last-minute prep I got
last-minute prep Lorraine
there's no mere premiere it's the movie
that I mean everyone well happens with
everyone a lot of people are dying to
see this movie and listen I may not be
going with you but I can be dang sure I
can get your red carpet ready you ready
yeah yeah okay okay we got to get you
ready for the world premiere the red
carpet of Marvel Studios Avengers and
game are you ready let's do it
the reactions interested shocked Oh Abbi
yeah I'm used by a fine anecdote no
Captain America alive dr. strange
snapped my friend Joe who you're worthy
come on must rewatch all 21 Marvel
Cinematic Universe film what was your
favorite scene to work on who's your
favorite member of the cast what would
you like working with the Russo brothers
I'm no perfect
[Music]
interesting fascinating shocked oh my
700 terrible amuse you card Lorraine
you're ready 2676 mm yeah have a rest
day at some point Lorraine I never need
to rest good answer but for me okay all
right so worthy you are you very much
iron you all please do not miss the
marvel studios adventures end game red
carpet world premiere live from Los
Angeles this Monday April 22nd on marvel
calm and be sure to see Marvel Studios
Avengers endgame in theaters opening
April 26 all right am so ready tell us
how you are emotionally preparing
yourselves to see Marvel Studios
Avengers endgame and hash tag Earth's
Mightiest show hold on to your friends
give everybody a hug cross your fingers
cross your legs cross your toes cross
your mind listen we'll see you next time
I'm Langston I'm Lorraine this is Marvel
your universe
thanks for watching us maybe a show if
you like this please like this leave us
a comment and subscribe to the Marvel
channel or click the box over there to
watch our last episode so um how are you
emotionally preparing oh I'm just ready
to see that purple jerk get punched in
the face